[Music]
hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A I am Jason Bradley and I'm so glad
that you've decided to join us and break
bread with us we are going to open the
word of God I know you're searching for
answers and guess what the Bible has the
answers and we have some wonderful
panelists here that will be answering
your questions from the word of God so I
would suggest that you grab a pen and a
piece of paper and jot down some of
these scriptures that they'll be sharing
with you because four and five minutes
is not a lot of time to answer some of
these questions so you'll want to jot
that down and uh refer back to to that
later uh for your personal study I want
to share this Bible verse with you it's
taken from Romans chapter 15
verse4 for whatever things were written
before were written for our learning
that we through the patience and comfort
of the scriptures might have hope if
you're searching for hope it is found in
the word of
God if you're sitting there and you're
wondering how you can send us your
questions you may text your questions to
618 228
3975 again that number is 618 228
3975 or you can email us at bible QA
3abn.org
at 3abn uncore official again that's
3abn uncore official my panelist that I
have here today we have Pastor James
rafy welcome Pastor
rafy good to be here Jason Daniel
looking forward to the all the questions
that are come in and of course getting
those Bible answers back out amen amen
and we have Professor Daniel parin we
all we we refer to you as professor at
times but you're an excellent student of
God's word Jesus God's word is the great
teacher and I'm happy to be here with
God's word amen amen Pastor raffy would
you pray for us before we start the
program yes let's pray Father in Heaven
just want to thank you again for our
viewers for their interest in studying
your word for how you have led them by
the Holy Spirit to ask these questions
and father again that your Holy Spirit
would give them the answers uh we pray
for this program that you'll be with us
you'll guide and direct us as we move
Through the Bible passages that will
bring Clarity to the questions that have
been asked be with each of the viewers
touch their hearts also so we give you
this time we give you our hearts in
Jesus name amen amen thank you and we're
going to come to you with this first
question okay someone sent it via email
says I've heard that the wine in the
Bible was not always fermented an
alcoholic how do we know if wine in the
Bible was alcoholic or not specifically
when Jesus turned water into
wine that is a great question and there
are several considerations that we want
to uh look at to help us to navigate the
topic of drinking alcohol from a
Biblical perspective you know the first
one basically is to understand that the
Bible contains many texts that prohibit
the use of in toxicating drink so right
there we have biblical evidence that the
Bible is telling us to be aware of and
warning us against drinking intoxicating
drinks for example in Leviticus 108
through1 or Proverbs 23
29-35 the Bible talks about staying away
from intoxicating drinks and not even
looking upon it as it changes its shape
and its form because it bites like an
Adder now number two the Bible contains
many texts that describe wine as a
blessing such as Genesis 27:28 and Psalm
104:4 and 15 so right here you have a
seeming contradiction how can the Bible
be warning us against intoxicating drink
and at the same time describing wine as
a blessing there must be a difference in
the type of wine the Bible is talking
about and there is now both in the
Hebrew and in the Greek the words for
wine yayin and onos can refer to either
unfermented grape juice or F
fermented uh grape juice or what we know
as wine that is intoxicated right that
is alcoholic excuse me that is alcoholic
and intoxicates so both of those words
can refer to either wine that is not
fermented and not not intoxicating or it
can refer to wine that is uh natural and
has no fermentation or intoxication so
the Bible is telling us that we should
stay away from intoxicating drink but we
should we can take in the wine that
there's a blessing in the grape juice
and the wine and therefore there must be
a difference between the two and a
question is how do we know the
difference specifically how do we know
the difference in relationship to for
example Jesus Christ blessing the or
turning the water into wine at the
wedding feast or giving it a putting a
blessing upon it so the Bible both
prohibits and commends the use of wine
depending on whether it is fermented or
unfermented without any contradiction
since unfermented wine is hugely
different from fermented wine and we can
see that in 2 Timothy 3 and: 16 so
number five true biblical Temperance
requires the judicial use of that which
is good and complete abstinence from
that which is not good and we can read
about that in Exodus 15:26 and 1 Peter
211 so this last point is really
significant it really help us to
understand that the Bible teaches
Temperance in eating and drinking from
that even which is good or Allowed by
God there are times in the Bible when
Paul for example uh rebukes the
Believers who are eating at the Lord's
Supper to the point of drunkenness now
they're not eat eating wine they're
eating food but they're overdoing it and
so there are Bible verses that talk
about not staying long at wine or long
at food you can read about this in 1
Corinthians 11:20 and 21 when you come
together he says it's not to eat the
Lord's supper and eating and drinking
everyone eats before the other and one
is hungry and the other is drunken so
when we look at some of these verses
that actually say don't stay long at
wine or or drink and we we think well
that's the good stuff it's because we
should still not indulge even in the
good stuff to the point of drunkenness
when we look at Bible verses that
prohibit the use of wine altogether
that's intoxicating or fermented wine
and that's what we that's how we answer
the question in relation to the marriage
Feast at Canaan Jesus obviously did not
turn that water into fermented wine or
intoxicating wine but he did turn it
into the grape juice that God has
blessed but again we don't want to stay
too long drinking even the good stuff
because that can lead to a fermentation
of the stomach and intoxication or
drunkenness as Paul says in 1
Corinthians 11:20 and 21 amen I think
that about clears it up thank you Pastor
rafy uh
Daniel I recently watched a TV series
called The Red Tent I read Genesis
chapter 34 and it got me confused
because my understanding was that Dina
was raped why does the Bible will not
say she was raped it seems like Dina did
not protest this is from Chenise out of
South Africa all right good question
here and I can't tell you how many times
I've heard a student say to me but Mr
parin that's not the way it was in
Veggie Tales or The Prince of Egypt or
the Ten Commandments with Charlton hon
so uh hear ye hear ye I mean this in all
gentleness and seriousness read the
Bible uh Revelation 1:3 says uh blessed
is He who reads and Jesus says it is
written he did not say it will be
performed or animated for you so let's
read the Bible Genesis 34 and we'll look
at the first couple of verses for you uh
Genesis 34:1 says now Dina I think the
Hebrew pronunciation would be daa but I
go by Dina here Dina the daughter of
Leia whom she had born to Jacob went out
to see the daughters of the land so
she's probably in her teens here as we
look at the biblical chronology and she
is going out unaccompanied apparently to
see the ways and customs of the people
around her perhaps she felt lonely at
home without any other sisters as far as
we can tell and so she is engaging in an
unguarded interaction with the world
removing herself then from the parental
control that she needed and protection
and so she is intermingling here to see
and to be seen uh along with the people
of the world so she's not keeping
herself separate uh from the habits of
idolators and so the text here
highlights that she has a role she put
herself in danger physically as well as
spiritually and her father played a role
in this as well and what's the result of
that well we're going to see verse two
then and when sheam the son of hyar the
hivite prince of the country saw her he
took her and lay with her and violated
her now compared with the other actions
of the Canaanites of that era this is is
not unusual behavior promiscuity was a
part of their cultural system so it
seems but uh Dina and sheam they're not
married to each other but in his
worldview an unaccompanied young woman
like this was fair gain but he took her
all right he did the taking there is not
told here of any participation on her
part he took and violated the King James
version says defiled now the Hebrew word
there indicates uh action from a
position of strength power and dominance
and so that word violated is indicating
that regardless of whatever her
participation might have been or what he
assumed her participation to have been
he did the action and it was from his
position of strength and might well
verse three then goes on to say his soul
was strongly attracted to her and he
loved the young woman spoke kindly then
in verse four he tells his father get me
this young woman as a wife and then
Jacob hears that she had been defiled
this is a different Hebrew word here
that says that she had been sexually
defiled and so what's happening here is
that this is not godly love that's going
on he asks to marry her in verse 8 but
he is Desiring to begin an intermarriage
with their family willing to be
circumcised externally but this is not
according to God's will so here's what
the picture that we see as we put these
texts together in the Bible uh she was
in the wrong for where she was she put
herself in a dangerous situation both
physically and spiritually but that does
not erase uh what comes next he was 100%
totally in the wrong for taking her and
violating her whether or not she was a
participant or whether or not she seemed
to or he thought she was a participant
the text is clear that that sheam
violated and defiled her it doesn't use
the word rape but the picture is clear
there from the Bible and then we can
take from what the Bible says to
understand the story amen amen you know
it's interesting because the Bible
doesn't always contain certain words and
and situations but the principles are
there and so thank you for sharing that
uh Pastor rafy since every religion
claims that their religion is the True
Religion how do we know that adventism
is the true religion and that there
isn't another religion that we should be
following this is from ryanna out of
Bermuda thank you Ranna had a Bermuda
excellent question I can share this for
my own testimony I was was raised
Catholic and believing that was the true
church the worldwide Church uh Irish
Catholic and then uh I stumbled upon
this idea that I was going to church on
the wrong day my sister actually shared
that with me I thought she was crazy
everyone goes to church on Sunday and I
was sure that the Bible taught that
Sunday was the day to worship and so I
began to study the Bible actually with
Adventist with the purpose of getting my
sister out of the church and I
discovered that the word of God
clarified that issue in fact the word of
God clarifies every truth that seventh
day Adventists teach I would say that to
answer your question more directly the
reason why we know that 7 Day Adventist
uh church is God's Church God's Remnant
church is because of its position on the
word of God their position on the word
of God is very unique they believe that
the word of God is the sole Authority
for their Doctrine and teaching now
there are a lot of Christians in the
world today there are actually over two
billion Christians in the world today
about 1.3 billion or so of those
Christians are Catholic and they believe
the word of God to some degree but they
believe that tradition trumps God's word
and so does the authority of the church
so they can't be the true church if
their foundations not solely on the word
of God they would actually go to church
and worship God on a different day
designated by their church but not
designated by the word of God then
you've got about another billion
Protestants and other Orthodox
Christians they also Al claim to believe
the Bible but they don't follow the
Bible either they still follow man's
tradition and in fact a lot of the
Evangelical Protestant Christians don't
even consider the Old Testament
applicable to them so you've got a bunch
of Christians that believe Traditions
equal with the Bible you've got another
Bunch that believe that the New
Testament trumps the Old Testament New
Covenant versus old Covenant then you
got little groups that here and there uh
the Jewish faith of course believes in
the Old Testament but not the New
Testament you got Jehovah Witnesses
they've got their own Bible Mormons
they've got The Book of Mormon and of
course Adventists have Ellen White but
we believe Ellen White is secondary to
the Bible the Lesser light leading to
the greater light so to answer your
question I would say that the most
unique doctrine that we hold as Seventh
Day Adventist is the doctrine of the
word of God and that out of that truth
comes every other truth the Bible says
that God's word is a lamp to our feet
and a light to our path the Bible
indicates that God's people are clothed
with the righteousness of Christ the son
in Revelation 12:1 and they're standing
on the moon the Lesser light leading to
that greater light of the righteousness
of Jesus Christ in John 1:1 we're told
that the word in the beginning the word
was with God and the Word was God and
then the word was made flesh and dwelt
Among Us so the word of God inspired by
the holy spirit is the foundation of
Adventist teaching everything that they
teach is in harmony with the word of God
and that sets this church apart as
unique in the world today we are unique
because we are standing upon the truth
of God's word in fact in Revelation 12:1
17 it talks about a people who keep the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus the Commandments of
God of course we see as God's law given
at Mount Si we are the only church that
actually keeps all 10 of them based on
the word of God and then the testimony
of Jesus which is the spirit of Prophecy
that lesser light leading to the greater
light that illumines the Bible it's all
about the word of God following the word
of God who is Jesus Christ so it's all
about our relationship ship with Jesus
Christ so to answer your question
directly God's church is identified in
the world among the world Revelation
12:17 as the remnant Church who are
identified as holding on to God's word
that the remnant of the woman standing
on the word of God clothed with Christ's
righteousness keeping God's Commandments
and having the testimony of Jesus Christ
there's no other church that meets all
of those characteristics amen amen
excellent breakdown follow God's word
not tradition all right uh Dan in
reference to Revelation 12: 1-5 I have
heard it said that the woman is the
church and that the child is Jesus but
considering that the woman was present
before the child and Jesus created the
church a after he was 30 years old who
is the child if the woman is the church
this is from Roger all right Roger
you've already gotten an introduction
here for to Revelation 12 as Pastor
Rafford he was speaking but we see see a
woman in Revelation 12 and there's some
chronology here you have a woman first
and then a child and that's versus uh
12: 1 to 5 and then the child shows up
in verse uh six and then you have sorry
in verse 5 and then you have a woman
again in verse six and then later on in
the chapter so what is the woman uh you
mentioned the woman as a church and we
find evidence for that uh Paul writes
about that in 2 Corinthians 11:2 and
then in Ephesians 5 25 and a number of
other places as well 2 Corinthians 11:2
says for I am jealous for you with a
Godly jealousy I have betrothed you to
one husband that I may present you as a
chaste virgin to Christ Paul's writing
to the Christian Believers here says you
are a pure woman at least I'm offering
you describing God's Believers the
church uh of Believers in Christ as a
pure woman Ephesians 5:25 says husbands
love your wives just as Christ also
loved the church and gave himself for
her that he might sanctify and cleanse
her with the washing of Water by the
word and so here you have believers who
are filled with the word of God basing
their experience on the word of God and
they represent the Church Believers in
Jesus and of course there can be a
counterfeit there can be an impure woman
which we see in Revelation 17 but where
did Paul where did the New Testament
writers get this idea that a woman
represents a church and they borrowed it
they took it straight from God's word in
the old Testament listen to Zechariah
99:9 it says Rejoice greatly oh Daughter
of Zion shout oh daughter of Jerusalem
all right so we're thinking of a
daughter A a woman right here and then
he says behold your king is coming to
you this isn't speaking of a single
individual it's speaking of God's people
in the Old Testament and we can find
that phrase Daughter of Zion in a
variety of places listen to Jeremiah 6:2
says I have likened the daughter of Zion
to a lovely and delicate woman and we
see that same theme again in Ezekiel
chapter 16 but Paul is borrowing now
this imagery that God's people in the
Old Testament established on scripture
who had the message of the Gospel about
Jesus that was the woman who brought
forth then Jesus that child and uh
another piece of evidence here Joseph
had a dream back there in Genesis 37 and
he dreamed he said I I I saw the sun and
the moon and the 11 and 11 Stars bow
going down to me that would be the 12th
star and his father says are are we
really your father and your mother and
your 11 Brothers going to bow down to
you and so you have sun moon and stars
which are surrounding this woman in
Revelation 12 and we see that represents
uh Abraham Sarah sorry Abraham and not
be Jacob and his mother and the the 12
tribes of Israel and so this woman here
that gives birth to Jesus is the people
of Israel who have the god gospel
message who are standing on on scripture
they're clothed in righteousness and
that righteousness is that that son is
the righteousness from Christ and the
Moon is is God's word that gives
evidence that that reveals God's
righteousness so the the woman is the
Old Testament Church that brings forth
Christ but then it continues as Israel
and other nations join putting their
faith in scripture accepting the
righteousness of Christ and we see that
woman then continuing on in the prophecy
of re ation 12 amen well said thank you
all right now you may be sitting at home
and you're wondering well this these
questions sound amazing but I've got
questions of my own that I want to
submit to be answered on a future
program well here's how you can do that
you can text us your questions at 618
3975 again that's 618 228
3975 or feel free to email us at bible
QA
3abn.org Bible QA at 3abn.org
time in the Old Testament the 12 literal
tribes were situated around the
Tabernacle three on each side similarly
New Jerusalem has three gates on each
side will New Jerusalem be situated in
the same way three on each side with the
city centrally located are those of the
great multitude also divided in 12
tribes this is from
Shandra Shandra that's a great question
and one that we can find an answer to
and in fact we know in the context of
Revelation a very symbolic book that the
great multitude and the 144,000 are
actually one in the same group uh we
know this from the context of the
previous chapter as well as from the use
of the phrases heard and saw but if you
want a more detailed study on this you
can go to 3abn Bible answers.com that's
a a website of 3abn it has all these
different Bible questions and answers 3
ABM Bible ansers.com and you can look up
the question on the 100 44,000 but we're
going to deal specifically with your
question will the tribes of Israel will
the 144,000 redeemed of Israel be
situated around the Jeune Jerusalem in
the new Heaven and the new Earth John
14:2 tells us Jesus is talking here and
he says in my father's house that would
be in the New Jerusalem there are many
mansions many places and if it were not
so I would have told you i' go to
prepare a place for you every single one
of the redeemed is going to have a place
prepared for them within the new jerus
Jerusalem now it doesn't mean that we're
not going to have a place outside the
New Jerusalem we're told in Revelation
21 1 through3 that John saw the new
heavens and the new Earth and he saw the
first Heaven and the first Earth were
passed away and there was no more sea
now just pause there for a second in
Revelation 21:1 no more sea doesn't mean
there aren't going to be any more oceans
or any more places for fish and whales
Etc but that there's not going to be any
more vast uh uh expanses of ocean that
are taking up all the land mass that God
originally purposed man would take up
human beings would take up uh when he
created us in the Garden of Eden so what
we're going to see in the new Heaven and
new earth is there's going to be a lot
more land mass there's going to be no
more deserts there's going to be no more
Barren land every part of the new Earth
is going to be made habitable now when
you think about that the New Jerusalem
is about the size of the state of I'm
living in the United States so I'd say
the state of Oregon it's a big city
right it's as big as a state then
outside of that City you're going to see
people God's people inhabiting the earth
made new and most of that Earth is going
to be inhabitable there may be some
portions that have you know you know
some ocean type but nothing like we see
today with the Atlantic and the Pacific
and the Indian Ocean taking up vast
portions of the world the majority of
the land mass of the world it's going to
be much smaller so the the inhabitants
aren't going to Camp right around the
New Jerusalem in a sense you could say
they'll be around the New Jerusalem
because the Jerusalem is so big but not
right around the New Jerusalem in fact
we're told and I think it's really clear
here in Isaiah 65: 21 that we will build
houses and inhabit them that we will
plant Vineyards and eat the fruit of
them now we have a garden Jason and
Daniel and I were talking about the rafy
garden just before we got on today and
you know we've got the Watermelons and
the cantaloupe and the peaches and the
nectarines and the cucumbers and the
zucchini and right now we're eating
raspberries and tomatoes are coming on
we are planting garden right now can you
imagine what it's going to be like to
plant garden in the new Heaven and the
new Earth when Daniel there's no more
bugs right there's no more these creepy
crawly things coming in to devastate
everything and you know with us it's the
ground squirrels and you know the the uh
the the little guys that come under all
I'm trying to think now anyway the moles
yeah the mo exactly and there's none of
that in the new Heaven and the new Earth
is going to be food for all of God's
creatures and we are going to have a
place in the city and we're going to
build a place outside inside the city
but it's going to be spread out over the
entire Earth of course in the Old
Testament they had to stay close to the
sanctuary because they were in the
wilderness and but once they got in the
new in the New Canaan in the new uh uh
the the Heavenly the Earthly Canaan
excuse me the promised land they spread
out over many many miles and of course
once we get into the New Jerusalem
promised excuse me the new heaven
Promised Land we're going to spread out
over all the Earth so remember 3abn
Bible ansers.com that to get more sight
on the 144,000 in the great multitude
but definitely we're going to have a
place outside the city that we're going
to build but it's not going to be right
next to the city it's going to spread
out to all the Earth amen amen no more
GMOs on the new Earth either I love that
that's right all right Daniel I hear
other Christians say God told me this or
that how do I get the Lord to speak to
me like that this is from Marshall out
of Indiana all right Marshall this is a
practical question that I know that you
are not alone in asking I've heard I've
heard this statement before I God told
me I've even said things like that and I
think about something that David wrote
uh King David in Psalm 5:3 you see this
desire in what he wrote my voice you
shall hear in the morning oh Lord in the
morning I direct it to you and I will
look up this is an attitude of
expectation Lord I've I've communicated
I'm listening I'm waiting but I want to
resp respond to kind of the way you
wrote that question I want to say we
cannot get God to tell us anything
that's God's prerogative he's the one
who chooses who decides who knows what
we need to hear and how to get our
attention how best to get our Attention
our responsibility is not to get God to
speak but to learn how best to listen I
think about Eli who instructed Samuel
about this in 1st Samuel chapter 3 said
when when you sense God God's
communicating with you say Speak Lord
your servant is listening or your
servant heareth so how do we listen
Romans 10:1 17 is I think one of those
great texts that gives us a concise
illustration so then faith comes by
hearing isn't that what you want faith
comes by hearing well how do we hear the
rest of the text says hearing by the
word of God so we listen to God's Voice
through the reading of scripture the
application of it because what we find
written in the Bible is God's voice
speaking to us personally giving us
instruction that through the Holy Spirit
then we then identify how to apply it to
our situation that God's word is living
and active and the Holy Spirit is
working within us to bring about uh the
fruits of responding to the word of God
Jesus himself considered the words of
God to be inspired words for him when he
says in Matthew 4:4 quoting Deuteronomy
8:3 it is written man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God then
Jesus gives us this instruction in
Matthew 7:24 he says therefore whoever
hears these sayings of mine and does
them or puts them into practice I will
liken him or compare him to a man who
builds his house on a rock on a solid
foundation so we've got to spend time
listening to God's words in Scripture
and practically we got to slow down and
stop sometimes we ask God a question and
we rush off without spending time in his
presence to be able to then listen for
and learn and understand from scripture
and through the responding of the to the
holy spirit's prompting in our minds we
have to carve out some time truly allow
God to help us schedule that time for
him and then we also need to do our part
as far as possible to clear our lives of
sin I think of 1 Samuel 28 we're Saul is
wanting to hear from God but he has
pushed God's voice away because he has
unrepented sin that he has consistently
allowed to create a barrier between him
and God so if we're not living according
to the clear words of God that he's
already given us then God may not be
giving us any more additional
instruction Proverbs 28:9 says one who
turns away his ear from hearing the law
even his prayer is an
Abomination we need to do our part to
clear way distractions sometimes we're
so uh so consumed by things that we're
listening to and watching and reading
and jobs we have to do that we're
rushing through life and we can't slow
down and listen then we have to listen
for small things sometimes we want to
hear a big message from God and God may
have a small message for you and it may
may be a message that you don't have the
the privilege or uh kind of the the
bragging rights of saying to someone God
told me this God may be speaking to you
something in your life that is not for
you to share with with anything else
maybe it's a sin that we might count we
might count as a small sin that God
brings up in our lives for us to confess
God tells us those things sometimes we
don't want to hear them but we need to
be willing and excited to say Lord thank
you for sharing that message with me
reminding me of something I need to turn
away from God speaks also in ways that
we may not anticipate through through
others who are sharing God's word
through nature through uh through the
the other writings like Ellen White's
writing like uh the pages of scripture
and then we also finally we need to be
careful and humble about saying things
like God told me this we should not want
to boost our image in the eyes of others
look I've heard a message from God
instead we need to be uh be humble and
rep recognize that we too can perhaps
Mis mishear God's voice and so to be
very careful about saying this is God's
word for you we certainly know that's
true in God's word and we need to
rightly understand understand it and
apply it I hope that's helpful for you
in answering this question amen that was
a great answer amen yeah I mean some
people say God told me this and I'm like
I know good and well God didn't tell you
that because it doesn't line up with his
word so true that's that's very
important Pastor rafy Will some people
burn longer than others I've heard
people say they could not worship a God
that would keep someone alive so that
they could burn longer this is from Lee
out of
Texas well this is a sensitive subject
Le thank you for your question it's one
we need to understand from a Biblical
perspective of God's justice and love
because Justice is a part of God's love
just like Mercy is a part of God's love
it's a part of his character and we
could ask this question from another
perspective will some of the wicked
burned for a shorter time than others
for example will Hitler who was
responsible for the mass murder of
millions uh will he suffer longer than
let's say an unrepentant liar who misled
people or stole from people but never
really murdered anyone uh Exodus chapter
20 talks about God's character in verses
5 and six as a part of the transcript of
his law the law of God is a transcript
of his character and we know that
because when we read these verses it
says for I the Lord thy God I'm a
jealous God that's talking about his
character visiting the iniquities of the
fathers upon the children under the
third and fourth generation of them that
hate me and showing Mercy unto thousands
of them that love me and keep my
commandments so there you have a perfect
revelation of God's character in the
midst of his law he is merciful and he
is just and God cannot negate either one
of those if God stops being just or
stops being merciful he stops being God
and we cease to exist and so God is
warning us right now as the Bible
teaches that we will be award rewarded
according to our works but there is an
option and that is Jesus Christ he has
given us salvation by taking upon
himself the punishment that we deserve
in in Romans Chapter 2 Paul talks about
the goodness of God in Jesus Christ that
leads us to repentance he talks about
the fact that we shouldn't judge others
we are in no wise any better than anyone
else but he also talks about the fact
that if we despise The Riches of his
goodness that leads us to repentance we
will treasure up uh wrath in our
Hardness of Heart against the day of
Wrath and the righteous revelation of
God's judgment who will render to every
man according in to his deeds to them
who by pen continuance and well-doing
seek for Glory and Honor immortality and
eternal life and them who are
contentious and do not obey the truth
but obey unrighteousness indignation and
wrath tribulation and anguish upon every
soul of man that does evil the Jew first
and also the Gentile so sometimes truth
can be better understood when we look at
the two extremes you know the one
extreme in relation to God's Wrath and
uh um Hellfire is the idea that uh no
one's going to suffer God isn't gonna
God is too good to destroy anyone it's
universalism everyone's going to be
saved and God is not going to destroy
anyone The Other Extreme of course is
the idea that God is going to burn
sinners unrepentant sinners in a place
uh identified as hell in a place that's
ruled and managed by Satan and his
angels for all eternity and they're
going to suffer uh endlessly throughout
the Eternal ages forever and ever and of
of course that's just a misunderstanding
of the of the use of that phrase forever
in the Bible the balance to all of this
is not the extreme that God will not
punish the the lost the wicked he will
punish that's very clear when we read
these verses but also that God will not
punish them for all eternity that would
be mean that would be harsh that would
be so unlike a god of Mercy but again
the lack of punishment would be unlike a
God of Justice so between these two
extremes we find God's love go a God who
would never punish the wicked in
Hellfire for all eternity but that a God
who is just a god who's just love will
punish the wicked in fire in Hellfire
according to the works or according to
their deeds and for some people that's
going to be longer than for other people
now why would we question the justice of
God when we ourselves understand the
fairness of punishment for crimes a mass
murderer a thief a rapist a drug dealer
all are sentenced according to their
crimes and our own IAL system here on
planet Earth now the sentences are not
all of the same duration of severity
because the crimes are different and we
have no problem with this do we we call
it justice and yet it is imperfect at
times and unfair because well human
beings don't always get all the evidence
of the facts right and sometimes people
are set up or framed that happens all
the time but God has all the evidence he
understands all the motives he sees the
complete lack of remorse among the
wicked ACC according to Revelation 1691
they don't want to repent and if if we
can understand and accept a justice
system that is faulty for the punishment
of various crimes how much more the
justice of God that is Heavenly and
perfect so in conclusion it is a fact
that God will punish to different
lengths of time those who are unrepented
of their sins because some of them have
treasured up more wrath against the day
of Wrath than the righteous revelation
of God but God will not punish any
sinner for all eternity thank you for
that explanation that's comforting
that's comforting uh Daniel I've learned
that nothing is impossible for God and
Matthew 21: 22 says and whatever you ask
and prayer you will receive if you have
faith if that's the case can God answer
my unrealistic prayer if it is morally
good but doesn't necessarily have to do
with God this is from Liam out of New
York all right and this is a good
question and it's a recurring question I
will agree that nothing is impossible
for God nothing that power is able to
perform in his omnipotence God cannot go
against his own nature in his
omnipotence God cannot give us things
that are not for our own not for our
greatest good according to his perfect
wisdom because that would go against his
character and nature and God cannot stop
being God and replace himself with
someone else such as me and my sinful
Desir for example so with that in mind
let's look at this text in Matthew 21:
21 and 22 so when Jesus so Jesus
answered and said to them assuredly I
say to you if you have faith that Line's
important and do not doubt you will not
only do what was done to the Fig Tree
but also if you say to this mountain be
removed and be cast into the sea it will
be done and whatever things you ask in
prayer believing you will receive so I
want you to see that qualifying phrase
there if you have faith I'm going to
return to a verse I just used in the
previous question where we were to be
listening according to the word of God
and now same verse he sorry Romans 10:17
we will be speaking according to the
words of God according to to Faith so
then faith comes by hearing and hearing
by the word of God so if you have faith
to ask of God then that Faith true faith
is going to have to be according to the
word of God if it is not then regardless
of what label I put on it if I am asking
for things that are not according to
God's perfect will then I'm not really
asking in faith I'm asking according to
my will rather than God's will so
regardless of of what we may say it is
if we call it uh with the label Faith
even if I say it's morally good or
morally neutral even God's the one who
knows what is for my own good and I'm to
ask him Lord what give me wisdom what
should I ask you for what should I pray
for so then I can in faith ask in line
with God's word and God's will God would
not be loving to give me something that
was not for my own for my best good and
nor is he honored to put my will above
his own so what kind of Faith do we ask
in it's the faith in Jesus it's the
faith in what he desires what he Wills
for us seeking what he seeks not seeking
what I seek so uh we want to allow our
will to be brought into Unity with his
will so that we can then ask for what he
already desires to give because he knows
what's best for me and even Jesus who
was sinless he prayed in this manner he
said Lord thy will be done so anytime
that we pray in such a pray uh way where
we are asking for my will to be done we
should be weary of prayers like that and
asking for things that satisfy our own
desires so God will prompt you God
prompts us to to pray for things that he
desires for us to ask for because there
are things that he desires to give I'll
give you two texts here at the end James
1 15 if any of you lacks wisdom or if
you don't know what to pray for let him
ask of God who gives to all liberally
and without reproach and it will be
given to him Lord I want to ask in faith
right Faith true Faith trusting not my
will but your will and God will will
respond to that prayer he'll honor it
and then Romans 8:26 last text here
likewise the spirit also helps in our
weaknesses for we do not know what we
should pray for as we ought that might
be your situation I know it's mine many
times but the spirit himself makes
intercession for us with groanings which
cannot be uttered that the Holy Spirit
prompts us to be able to pray in faith
in accordance with the will of God so
when we ask for the Holy Spirit put
those things on our mind that we can
pray for so it's not not things that
just satisfy what I want but satisfies
what you desire to give amen amen Pastor
rafy are there consequences if someone
who believes in God who does not drink
alcohol nor smokes cigarettes but dates
or even marries another believer who
does drink alcohol or smoke cigarettes
this is from a viewer in
Virginia great question uh from that
viewer in Virginia you know smoking and
drinking are fairly large lifestyle
choices um will they impact you if you
date someone who smokes and drinks will
they impact you if you marry someone who
smokes and drinks absolutely the impact
is going to be significant you see for
example secondhand smoke is so dangerous
in the United States that the United
States established laws to restrict all
smoking in public places uh except for
designated or restricted places or
places in the open air including bars
you cannot smoke in public you cannot
smoke I remember years ago when we used
to to travel we were traveling by plane
smoking was in the back of the plane and
my wife and I would always try to get
seats as far to the front as possible
because that smoke of course would drift
down through the non-smoking section of
the plane and we'd have to inhale it and
secondhand smoke is deadly in fact they
found that secondhand smoke could be
more deadly than the initial smoke
that's inhaled by the person who is
smoking alcohol is so also dangerous
it's so dangerous that in
1920 the 18th Amendment to the
Constitution prohibited the
manufacturing and sale of alcohol and
that continued on for the next 13 years
until 1933 you may ask well why did they
go ahead and turn that or repeal that in
the 21st amendment why did they do away
with the prohibition of alcohol did
alcohol all of a sudden become a
blessing did it become something that
was okay uh to partake of did it become
something that was healthy for you no
indeed not they repealed that because
they couldn't manage it they couldn't
enforce the government was not able to
enforce the prohibition of alcohol and
so they decided to go ahead and make it
legal and then they've been making all
kinds of money on the taxation of
alcohol ever since so the Bible tells us
and there's a couple of verses I want
you to consider here for example
Galatians 6: 7 and 8 um do not be
deceived God is Not mocked for whatever
we sow we reap um he that SWS to the
flesh shall of the flesh reap corruption
he that SWS to the spirit shall of the
spirit reap everlasting life now you
said in your question if a Believer
marries another believer who's smoking
and drinking well there are a lot of
people who profess to believe in Jesus
but the Bible is very clear in 1
Corinthians chapter 6 uh verses 19 and
20 it says here and I'll just read this
from from the Bible I have on my table
here what know you not that your body is
the Temple of the Holy Ghost which is in
you which you have of God and you are
not your own for you are bought with a
price therefore glorify God in your body
and in your spirit which are Gods so if
you are a professed believer in Christ
and and you don't understand that your
body is the temple of God and you're
taking in you're inhaling smoke that
actually causes death proven
scientifically and you're drinking
alcohol that also shortens life and
causes death and by the way that smoke
causes death not only to yourself but to
the other person that you're supposedly
in love with and marrying or dating then
you your profession of belief in Jesus
Christ is shallow and maybe it's just a
profession it's not a reality uh
Believers are going to recognize that
their bodies of the temp of the Holy
Spirit they're going to recognize that
they owe it to themselves in go as God's
Temple and to those around them to their
neighbors people they don't even know to
love one another as Christ has loved us
and therefore they are not going to be
smoking or drinking and you want to be
sure to marry a Believer who's more than
just a professed believer someone and
dat a Believer who's more than just uh
saying that they believe in Jesus but
they're actually living it in their
lives because there are consequences to
all our decisions in life we are
affected physically mentally and
spiritually by those around us and
especially by those we choose to date or
marry for all eternity and by the way
alcohol in the long term can actually
change the personality of individuals
you can marry someone uh thinking that
they're a certain person and five or 10
years down the road after alcohol takes
its toll that person can become a
completely different individual amen
that was an excellent breakdown thank
you Pastor rafy Daniel Daniel 25: 27
talks about a time times and half a time
this is interpreted as being 3 and a
half years where in the Bible can you
show that a time equals one year this is
from Karen all right a great question
Daniel 7:25 that's right there's not 25
chapters all the way in Daniel So Daniel
7:25 and let's let's just read that
right off the bat here uh he shall speak
pompous words against the most high
shall persecute the Saints of the most
high and shall intend to change times
and law then the Saints shall be given
over into his hand for a time and times
and half a time now the use of times
here earlier on in the verse Changing
Times and laws that's a different Hebrew
word than the time times and half a time
now this is a uh a prophetic picture
here symbolic images this is actually a
little horn power a religious political
power representing papal of Rome that we
see that through history and then it's
paired with a symbolic time frame time
times in half a time and what does that
represent do we know that that time
times in half a time that the time
refers to one year so three and a half
years in this case I've got three three
reasons at least three why we understand
this to be three and a half years the
first two are going to be good the
second one's not the best or the third
one is not the best but I'll throw it at
you at the end anyway if I have time so
we discover that this time times and
half a time is a prophetic time period
that is supposed to be specific and
measurable so we should be able to
understand it as a time period we can
recognize and then there are parallel
time periods that we find in the Book of
Revelation so I want to take you to
Revelation 11 verse 2 and 3 and it uses
there uh a time period of measuring
sorry measuring the temple of God
excluding the outer Court which is given
over to the Gentiles and then they will
tread the holy city underfoot for a
period of 42 months 42 months there's 36
months in 3 years then six more months
gets you to 42 so you got 3 and A2 years
is equal to 42 months and then
progressing then to verse three of
Revelation 11 I will give power to my
two witnesses and they will prophesy
1,260 days clothed in sackcloth and so
we have this parallel construction 42
months equal to 1260 days so 3 and 1/2
years is 1260 days and so the 360 days
uh sorry the 1260 days represents 3 and
a half prophetic years so a prophetic
year is 360 days this is not a solar
calendar year of 365 and a quarter days
nor is it the lunar calendar year of of
the Hebrew calendar which the months had
29 or 30 days so then we're going to
keep on going to Revelation 12:6 where
we find the time period again of
1,260 days and this is where God's
people the church are in in a period of
persecution and uh then we find that
same time period again later on in that
very chapter Revelation 12 13 and 14 but
that time period is called this familiar
time frame from from Daniel 7 a time
times and half a time so we got 42
months 1260 Days A Time times and half a
time all of them equaling the same three
and a half year time period all right
now we know that to be true because when
we apply the day for a year principle
with with this this is our second
evidence that it's verified by the
historical events that confirm this
prophecy so in 538 with the overthrow of
uh the the plucking up of those three
little horns finally with the ostrogoths
in 538 papal Authority uh has dominance
in Europe and it lasts for
1,260 literal years representing the
prophetic years prophetic days until
1798 confirming that our understanding
of a Time representing a year is
accurate now now the last one here
Daniel 4:16 we find a vision that's
given to Nebuchadnezzar where he uh he
sees that he becomes a beast and seven
times pass over him this is that uh
Aramaic word Edon well seven times it's
not going to be seven months because we
know from verse 33 that it says your
your claws your your nails will grow
like eagle's claws and your hair like uh
your hair like the feathers well hair
grows about a half an inch a month and
your nails about an eighth of an inch a
month so seven months doesn't make sense
seven years for what times represents
here is really the only good solution
here so we understand from those three
reasons that a Time represents a year
and 1260 years is the the pro prophetic
time of Daniel 7:25 amen proven from the
Bible oh man I can't believe our time is
just about running out but we're not
done yet we're going to take a brief
break we're going to show you how you
can send your questions in to be
answered on future programs by our
panelists from from the word of God and
then we will be right back don't go
anywhere we'll see you
shortly if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn .tv that's
Bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org
may have sure you know I have already
read Romans 10:17 twice in this hour and
I think that's the invitation to hear it
one more time so we can fix it in our
minds now faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the word of God may God bless
you and enrich you as you hear the word
of God day by day amen amen amen and I
would like to just go back to the
question about wine in the Bible whether
it's fermented or unfermented you know
God's Sav people are to be filled with
the Holy Spirit and not drunk with wine
uh as noted in this following verse let
me just share it with you it's in
Ephesians
5:18 be not drunk with wine wherein is
excess but be filled with the spirit now
the Greek word for excess is a sodia and
it means
unsaved and therefore we could read the
verse this way and be not drunk with
wine wherein is excess or unsaved but be
filled with the spirit so the idea we
get from this is that the the Bible is
telling us to keep the Mind clear to
keep the Mind sharp to keep the Mind
able to think it's not just talking
about fermented wine it's talking about
gluttony it's talking about Ting it's
talking about um being drunk with
gluttony as well as or as the
possibility of course of being drunk
with fermented wine or alcohol so this
was God's purpose for his Old Testament
people to be to have the Mind clear to
be uh filled with the spirit and not
filled with drunkenness and it is God's
purpose for his New Testament Church for
us today we want to keep our minds clear
and sharp so that we can hear the Holy
Spirit speaking to us as uh Daniel
shared we can know the voice of God and
we can allow God to direct us in our
daily lives to be Witnesses and lights
for him on planet Earth amen amen thank
you so much Pastor rafy thank you
Professor Daniel pin thank you so much
for joining us and answering these word
these questions from the word of God we
want to thank you for submitting your
questions thank you for spending this
time with us and we encourage you to
study God's word and show thyself
approved until next time God bless
[Music]